a downsized bedroom here one third of  humans don't get enough sleep having  raised their offspring this pair of  aging lovebirds have moved to a smaller  nest the man attempts to cast off what  he believes our unneeded vestiges of the  past the woman stands her ground in the  face of conflict the man relents night  time for some clutter leads to stress  stress inhibits sleep which leads to  more stress prolong loss of sleep can  result in weight gain premature wrinkles  and impaired judgment their sleep is  going extinct as morning breaks they  take action  coordinating their attack  they put that adversaries in their place  and miraculously they reclaimed that  domain  at last they are victorious and their  reward is a good night's sleep  [Music]